[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه
انذار
الامريكي
واضح للجمهوريه في النواب حتى الان
بعد انسحاب روسيا القوات الاوكرانيه تتقدم
في خرسون وتحذيرات من كمين روسي
السيستاني يكذب اعلام ايران وينفي اي
تصريحات نسبت اليه حول موقف رافض
للاحتجاجات ودعم النظام
بيان امريكيا اوروبي يصف هجوم الحوثي على
ميناء قناب الارهابي ويطالب المليشيات
الالتزام بالقانون الدولي
[موسيقى]
في اخر تحديث للارقام ارقام النتائج
الاوليه للانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه ففي
مجلس النواب وفقا لشبكه سي ان ان حصل
الجمهوريون حتى الان على مئتين 209 مقاعد
فيما حصد الديمقراطيون 192 مقعدا وتتوقع
سي ان ان حصد الجمهوريين 16 مقعدا اضافيا
ليصل الاجمال الى 225 مقعدا بينما سيصل
عدد مقاعد الديمقراطيين الى 195 اما بشان
المنافسه في مجلس الشيوخ والتي لم تحسم
نهائيا بعد فقد حصد الجمهوريون 49 مقعدا
في ما حصد الديمقراطيون 48 نقطه
[موسيقى]
وتتجه هو انظار الامريكيين الان الى
ولايتينفاده واريزونا التي يتنافس
الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون فيهما على مقاعد
مجلس الشيوخ فيما يتواصل حتى الان فرز
الاصوات في اريزونا تظهر النتائج تقدم
الديمقراطيين بفارق مريح من الاصوات
بحوالي مئه الف صوت بعد فرزي اكثر من 76%
من الاصوات اما في نيفادا وهي الولايه
التي مازالت متارجحه وسط تقدم طفيف
للجمهوريين بفارق نحو
15000 صوت بعد فرزي 84 بالمئه من الاصوات
لماذا تبقى معلقه حتى اللحظات الاخيره
فاذا فاز الجمهوريون سيكون لهم خمسون
مقعدا في مجلس الشيوخ مقابل 49
وسيكون علينا انتظار الحزم في جورجيا في
السادس من ديسمبر في جوله الاعاده واذا
تحققت المفاجاه وربح الدي مقعد الشيوخ في
نيفادا فسيعود المجلس لقب داتهم مجددا دون
انتظار نتائج الاعاده في جورجيا
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا شبكه مراسلين من واشنطن
مراسلات العربيه ناديه البلبيسي من نيفادا
مراسله العربيه ريتا سليمان ومن جورجيا
حسين الطود اهلا بكم جميعا ابدا معكم
ناديه من واشنطن ما وقع النتائج المحققه
حتى الان ان كان للجمهوريين او
للديمقراطيين على البيت الابيض
والتصريحات الطرفين الحزبين
عيني ابدا من هنا من البيت الابيض طبعا
بالامس الرئيس بعد تحدث بشكل من الرضا عن
النتائج رغم انهم لم يفوزوا بالاغلبيه في
مجلس النواب لكن هذه هذا النصر لجمهوريين
اذا اردت اتى بطعم الهزيمه بالنسبه للرئيس
استراتيجيه البيت الابيض الابيض كانت في
مكانها وهو تحذير الامريكيين بان
الديمقراطيه في خطر تاثير الرئيس السابق
الدولار ترامب على هذه الانتخابات وبالفعل
مرشحي الرئيس في ولايه متارجحه مثل
سلفانيا خسروا مقعدا كانوا يعني مؤمن
للجمهوريين كانوا في السابق يحتلوا سنه
الجمهوري وبالتالي البيت الابيض الان ربما
اعطي مساحه للتحرك للحديث مره اخرى على ان
رئيس قد يترشح لعام 20 24 في البدايه كان
المحللون ربما يقرون بان الرئيس بيضا عليه
ان يقرر اذا كان سيترشح ام لا بانه وضعه
صعب جدا بانه خصومه يهاجمون وينتقدونه
وايضا واصدقائه يهمسون بانه حان الوقت
لتسليم السلطه ربما لجيل شاب لكن اعتقد
كما قال لنا الرئيس بانه سيقرر في بدايه
العام المقبل حسب اعتبارا شخصيه مع عائلته
لكن عن كل الاحوال هذه الانتخابات اثبتت
بالفعل بانه استطلاعات ربما لا يمكن
المراهن عليها بشكل كبير لم تاتي بهذه
الموجه الحمراء والبيت الابيض يشعر برضا
كبير بانه حتى الان لا نعرف مصير مجلس
الشيوخ لكن ربما جورج او حتى اريزونا تعطي
النصر للديموقراطيين في اسوا الاحوال يمكن
ان نعود لنقطه الصفر وهي 50 50 طبعا الصوت
الفارق هو لنائبه الرئيس كامله هارس همم
ربما بهذه همم بهذه الختام يعني اذا سمحتي
ابدا اذهب الى الاجازه الصحفي الان جايك
سلفني يتحدث عن مؤتمر الجيت وانت الذي
يشارك فيها الرئيس
شكرا جزيلا لك همم ناديه انتقل همم الى
ريتا سليمان من نيفادا ريتا حسب اخر رساله
كنت معنا فيها كانت تقدم للمرشح الجمهوري
حيث تتواجدين هل من تحديثات
صحيح همم لا زال لا زالت عمليه الفرز
والاحتساب تهتم في مركز المركز الرئيسي
همم في شمال اا
اه
مدينه
هذه المقاطعه كما ذكرت تحيه حوالي 75% من
الكثافه السكانيه في عموم ولايات نيفادا
في هذه المقاطع تحديدا التقدم للمرشحه
الديمقراطيه ولكن اذا احتسبنا همم النتائج
من المقاطعات الاخرى في ولايه نيفادا
التقدم هو للمرشح الجمهوري ادم
منافسه الديمقراطيه همم النتائج عندما
سالنا في هذا المركز تحديدا مات من
المتوقع ان تخرج النتائج قالوا لنا انه
ليس قبل اليوم الجمعه وما يحصل انه بسبب
اعتماد همم التصويت عبر البريد من الخارج
لاول مره في تاريخ نيفادا يتم تاخر بفرز
النتائج لهذا السبب ستتاخر همم سيتاخر
اعلان ان نتائج همم وايضا بالتالي انا
اتصالات ايضا لمعرفه تطورات في اريزونا
همم اذا سمحت لي اود ان اشير بانه
6 حوالي 600 الف صوت يتم احتسابها بسبب
الخطا التقني يوم الانتخابات في همم
مقاطعه ماريكو باكانتي همم يؤدي الى هذا
اخر خبر ومع احتساب 62,000 من اصل 600,000
صوت هناك تقدم للمرشحين الديمقراطيين في
هذه المحافظه ان كان همم عن مقعد مجلس
الشيوخ هناك تقدم لماركلي على منافسه
الجمهوريه مصر همم اما همم العمليه الصعبه
عن همم
حاكم الولايه في اريزونا الذي يتنافس فيه
الديمقراطيه كيتي
سكرتيرات
بانه سكرتاريه الولايه هي المسؤوله عن
فارس هذه الانتخابات وبالتالي هناك
اتهامات بالتقسيط همم حيا لك هو بس تحديدا
مع انها ليست مشتركه بعمليه الفارس كونها
مرشحه همم ايضا المرشحه جمهوريه كاريليك
همم تتهم همم فكرهريه المحافظه همم
الولايه بعمليات احتيار وهذا هذا الهجوم
من المرشحين الجمهوريين على عمليه الفرز
في هذه المقاطعه ادى لجعلها بؤره
للمعلومات المضلله همم في المقاطعه ونحن
نعلم التهديدات التي طالت الموظفين
والعاملين في قطاع الانتخابات على في عموم
البلاد وليس فقط في هذه الولايه ولكن الان
الوضع متشنج جدا عمليات الفرز على قدم
وساق وهمم الان بينما نتحدث هناك مؤتمر او
مقابله اعلاميه لك تريد ان همم
تنشر فيها ما يحصل من تطورات وهمم
سنتابعها طبعا عندما سالنا موظفي الولايه
كيف تتم عمليه الفرز ولماذا كل هذا الوقت
الذي تاخذه هناك فارس يدوي على عده مراحل
ان كان في همم التصويت عبر البريد كل مغلف
على حدا يتم التاكد امضاء على المغلف
الخارجي ثم ما بداخله يتم وضعه في صندوق
خاص ليتم احتساب ايضا في مرحله اخرى وذلك
بسبب قانون السريه احتفاظا بالسريه في
عمليه الفرز لذلك تاخذ كل هذا الوقت واريد
ان اشير ايضا همم على نقطه مهمه بانه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه السابقه همم تم اعلان
النتيجه النهائيه بعد تسعه ايام من
الانتخابات وبالتالي نتوقع ان تاخذ ايضا
همم
دائما بحسب موظفي السكرتاريه نعم انتقل
الى جورجيا واحسن الطود هناك اذن الجوله
الاعاده هي التي ستحسم ان النتائج التي
ستكون بالسادس من ديسمبر ما هي اخر
التحديثات عندك حول هذا التمديد
تحيه لك راويه كله على ان تتجه الى جورجيا
بدانا بالفعل نشعر باجواء الحمله
الانتخابيه الحديثه الان يتركز على جماعه
التبرعات
هرش الوطن قالت انها جمعت منذ البارحه الى
اليوم اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين و300,000$ من
اجل الحملاتها واعلى انها ستقوم بحملات
انتخابيه عند خاصه في المناطق الماهوله من
اجل اقناع او تحفيز الناخبين نسيمه من
المؤدين حتى الجمهوريين المعتديين كما
وصفتهم وايضا من مؤيدين المرشحه الثالث في
الانتخابات
من اجل التصويت لهرش همم طبعا همم اعلنت
انها تعمل بان يقوم ضمان ترامب ودستانس
وهما طبعا نعرف ان هناك خلاف بينهما في
زياره جورجيا من اجل الدعامه يريدون ان
يكون له دعم كبير من جميع الجمهوريين الان
لا يوجد الان مساحه همم مساحه اي خلاف بين
جمهوريه او على هرش الواقع الكون مقعد
جورجيا سيحصل من
يسعد على القمر ستكون الاغلبيه همم
سمعنا العديد من القاده الجمهوريين مثل
تذكروز الذي هو الان اليوم جاء الى جورجيا
ليكون مع
حرشه التي وايضا
وعد على عدد كبير اعضاء
هم في هرش الوتر
بالمناسبه وزير الخارج
خلص بدات همم
تقول انها تعمل رفايل برنامجا اعلن انه لن
يستسلم وسيعمل على بالنسبه للدوره لدوره
الاعاده
من الديمقراطيون اعلن انهم سيستثمرون
6 مليون دولار في الولايه من اجل دعم همم
حمله ورنات
ترامب
زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ دفعوا
ملايين الدولارات
حماسيه بين الطرفين نتوقع ان تكون الحمد
لله وايضا الانتخابات ال- ال- اعاده
الدوله
ربما اكثر هذه المره
حسين بكل همم التحديثات من عندك من جورجيا
واشكرك على هذه الرساله وايضا جزيل الشكر
لك ريتا سليمان وايضا لمراسلتنا نادي
البلبيسي
[موسيقى]
وجهها الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب انتقادات من الجمهوريين بعد سلسله
من الخسائر في الانتخابات النصفيه طالت
المرشحين الذين اختارهم هذا الامر قد يضعف
موقف ترامب الى حد ما وسط التوقعات
باعلانه عن الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله ومع العدد الهائل من الفرص
الجمهوريه الضائعه كان الاندفاع لالقاء
اللومي على نيه على ترامب فورا بقدر ما
كان مفاجئا وفقا لتقرير نشرته صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه عدد كبير من
الجمهوريين انتقدوا ترامب على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ووسائل الاعلام مشيرين
الى انه مسؤول الى حد كبير عن النتائج
المخيبه للامال للانتخابات النصفيه حيث
تمت هزيمه عدد من المرشحين الذين كان قد
ايدهم في سباقات التنافسيه بما في ذلك
المرشحون لمنصب
ومقعد مجلس الشيوخ في ولايه بنسلفانيا
والمرشحون لمنصب الحاكم في ولايات مشجن
ونيويورك
[موسيقى]
اذا النتيجه النهائيه للانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه لمعرفه من سيسيطر على الكونجرس
تتطلب ربما لكن خريطه النتائج الاوليه حتى
اللحظه اوضحت ان الحزب الجوري يتجه الى
الحصول على الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي فيما لا يزال الترقب سيد الموقف
بالنسبه لمجلس الشيوخ النتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات حملات خمسه ملاحظات رئيسيه
الاول يتعلق بالرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب الذي تعرض الى نكسه انتخابيه
بعد ظهور النتائج التي احبطت مساعيه
للعوده لتصدر المشهد والترشح في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه حتى ان بعض
مستشارين ترامب اعتبروا نتائج الانتخابات
النصفيه جرحا لمستقبله السياسي وعليه
تاجيل اعلان ترشحه للرئاسه الذي كان يخطط
له الاسبوع المقبل بعد عدم تحقيق المد
الاحمر وفقه صحيفه واشنطوس ترامب بدوره
قال ان انتخابات التجديد النصفي تشكل نصرا
كبيرا من وجهه نظره الشخصيه لكنه اشعر الى
وجود خيبه للامال بشكل او باخر الاستنتاج
الثاني يتعلق بمن سيرشح الديمقراطيون في
انتخابات الرئاسه عام
2024 بعد التوقعات تتحدث عن حاكم
كاليفورنيا الديمقراطيه جابر يوسف
باعتباره منافسا قويا لبيضا بعد الاخير
نيته للترشح لولايه رئاسيه ثانيه بغض
النظر عن نتائج انتخابات التجديد النصفي
مشيرا الى ان قرره النهائي عما اذا كان
سيترشح ام لا سيكون في مطلع العام القادم
نتابعه
[موسيقى]
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
الباحث في الشان الامريكي احمد الحنطي
اهلا بك سيد احمد
يتحمل مسؤوليات اخفاق الموجه الحمراء هذا
ما يقوله
منتقد ترامب ان كان من داخل الحزب او من
خارجه عزل ذلك عده اسباب منها خساره اسماء
دعمها شخصيا ترامب وايضا فوز كبير لمنافسه
اللدود
الامر الذي يقال بانه بكسر للموجه
الترامبيه هل ترامب هو من يتحمل وحده
نتيجه هذه الانتخابات النصفيه حتى الان
لا بكل تاكيد ترامب لا يتحمل هذه لوحده
ولكنه يعني المثل يقول اذا وقع الجمل كثره
سكاكينه فهذا ما يحدث الان في الحزب
الجمهوري هناك محاوله للتخلص من ترامب هذه
الرغبه ليست جديده لدى المؤسسه التقليديه
في الحزب الجمهوري ولكن ممكن يواجهون
مشكله انه ناخبين ترامب الذين ادخلهم لقاء
لقواعد الحزب مخلصين له تماما وهم لا
يستطيعوا مواجهتهم في الانتخابات الاوليه
ولا يريدون خساره اصواتهم في الانتخابات
العامه لذلك كانوا يجارون ترامب وفي كل
مناسبه تظهر فرصه للتخلص منه كانوا
يحاولون ذلك لكن على كارهه ترامب ان لا
يسارعوا بالاحتفال شاهدنا نفس الامر
تقريبا بعد احداث 6 يناير عندما خرجت
السكاكين وخرجت الانتقادات وتوقع الجميع
ان ترامب راحل لم يمر اسبوع حتى ينام
يتوافدون واحد وراء الاخر لتقديم فرض
الولاء وطاعه
نعم طيب كيف قرات رساله بيضا بانه منفتح
على العمل مع
الجمهوريين هل برايك هنالك من ارضيه
مشتركه يمكن البناء عليها بين الحزبين
للعمل معا في مجلس الشيوخ ومجلس النواب في
ظل انقسام هائل بين الحزبين
حتى قبل انتخابات 20 20 كان يطرح نفسه
يعني كان رئيس توافقي يستطيع العمل مع
الطرف الاخر ويستطيع يعني تمرير مشاريع
مشتركه
ويستند بذلك على ارض الطويل في مجلس
الشيوخ
وما يطرح يزيد هذا الاحتمال في الفتره
القادمه هو الاقليه لها المتوقع للجمهوريه
في مجلس النواب
من سيقود مجلس النواب في الفتره القادمه
يعني غالبا سيكون كارثه ولكن ليس بالتاكيد
سيواجه مشكله كبيره اللي هي الفريدون
كوكيز الفريدون كوكس هم الفئه الاكثر
تشددا في مجلس يعني في في الجمهوريين في
مجلس النواب وهذه الفئه العمل معها صعب
جدا كانت دائما تسبب صداع كبير لمن يقود
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب اذا كانت
الاغلبيه كبيره يعني عندك 30 40 مقعد يعني
فوق ال 218 هذه يعطيك تستطيع ان تمر بعض
المشاريع بخساره 20 او 30 عضو من الفريدون
كوكس ولكن عندما تكون اغلبيتك خمسه وعشره
مقاعد انت تحتاج لكل صوت فيطرح البعض فكره
انه
مكارتي قد يحتاج الى اصوات الديمقراطيين
لتمرير بعض المشاريع بالتالي سيظهر للعمل
معهم لعلي يعني لن يكون عمل بشكل واسع
ولكنه بشكل محدود هذا اذا تحقق لانه في
سنوات اوباما عندما كانت تفريده كوكس يعني
تختطف اداره مجلس مجلس النواب وتجبرها على
كل شيء لم يلجا لم يلجئ القاده الجمهوريين
لتعاون مع الديمقراطيين من اجل تمرير اي
شيء طب من الاسم الجمهور الذي برايك
سينافس ترامب منافسه حقيقيه وجديه
هناك عده اسماء طبعا ابرز هذه سانتوس حكم
فلوريدا همم هناك همم
سيناتور هناك 2 كروز هناك بومبيو هناك
مايك بننس همم الاشكاليه ان اغلبهم لا
يجرؤ على مقارعه ترامب وجهها لوجهه يتمنون
ان لا يعلن ترم ترشحه بالتالي يعطيوهم
فرصه للترشح خصوصا ان كثيرا من هذه
الاسماء يعني الصغار في سن النسبيه همم
بالتالي يقول يعني انت تستطيع الانتظار
الى 28 لماذا تواجه ترامب في 24 دعك ترامب
ياخذها ويفوز يعني هذا هذه قد تكون
عندنا
فبالتالي ضد هذه الاشخاص وهذه الاشخاص لا
يريدون خساره في 2000 وهمم يعني في
الانتخابات الاوليه في 2016 هو كان الثاني
بعد ترامب لا يريد ان يخسر مره اخرى يريد
عندما يترشح ان يكون كره رقم واحد ويحصل
على ترشيح بسهوله شكرا جزيلا لك البحث عن
الامريكي احمد الحمد
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع في سياقها لكن بعد
قليل
روسيا تلجاولي انياب التنين
القوات الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اسابيع من الكاري والفرو
وتقدم ميزني اوكرانيا بالتزامل مع اجلاء
الموسكو المدنيين في مقاطعه خرسون جاء
اعلان وزير الدفاع الروسيه عن انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من الضفه اليمنى لنهر برو
في خرسون ليطرح اسئله حول هذا القرار
خلصون كانت من اول المدن الاستراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه التي سيطر عليها الروس في
السادس عشر من شهر مارس الماضي مما دفع
خبراء لوصف الانسحاب الروسي بانه نقطه
تحول مهمه في مسار هذه الحرب قبل اعلان
الانسحاب الروسي بساعات اعلن عن مقتل
مسؤول روسي كبير يدعى كريم ستريمو صوف
بحديث السير كان ستريم وسوف احد اشد
المؤيدين لضم موسكو لمنطقه خرسون خبراء
عسكريون ان هذا يعكس تراجع عن عسكريا
الروسيا امام التوغل الاوكراني في المنطقه
فيما يعتبر اخرون انا الانسحاب ربما يشكل
تكتيكا روسيا لاستدراج الق الاوكرانيه
ونصف الافخاخ امامها في المقابل ذهب
التحليلات الاعتبار ما يحدث ربما مقدمه
للعوده لطاوله المفاوته القوات الروسيه
التي سحبت من خرسون الى الضفه الغربيه من
نهر دنبرو بدات باستخدام اسلوب يعود الى
الحرب العالميه الثانيه يسمى انياب التنين
لوقف اي تقدم اوكرانيا المحتمل فما هي
انياب التانيه
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا من موسكو المحلل السياسي في
تنس دراف اهلا بك معنا سيد يفغيني يعني
قائد الجيش الاوكراني يقول بانه لا يمكن
تاكيد الانسحاب الروسي من اخرسيون حتى
الان لماذا هذا التشكيك الاوكراني
بانسحابكم انسحاب الجيش الروسي من خيركم
عن كون بعض القوات الروسيه تبقى في
المدينه في مدينه خرسون حسب بعض المعلومات
ومن جهه اخرى ربما اللغه نوع المصنع يعتقد
الخبراء الاوكرانيون جعلت كيا فلا تصدق
لهذه التصريحات وهذه الاجراءات التي تنوي
موسكو اتخاذها وبالتالي هناك الشكوك كبيره
جدا
تراود الاوساط العسكريه والسياسيه في
اوكرانيا وهي بتعبئه الحال تامل ربما
بالحصول على معلومات الدقه حول تواجد
القوات الروسيه في غرسون بعد بدء عمليه
الانسحاب اضافه الى ذلك طبعا هناك مخاوف
متعلقه بزرع للغام من قبل القوات الروسيه
قبل هذه العمليه
بالتالي يعني لا يمكن الان
القول بدقه ان بالفعل نحن امام مثل هذه
المناوره بالاضافه الى ذلك عاده ما لا
تعلن القوات المسلحه لاي بلد عن هذا
الاجراء همم وتسميها بالانسحاب وتستخدم
ربما عبارات اخرى مثل اعاده الانتشار او
اعاده تماضر
استعملت هذه المصطلحات ولكن سيدي افغين
يعني هذا الانسحاب سبقوا همم قرار روسي او
طلب من بوتين باجلاء المدنيين من خيرسون
ما دلالات هذا الطلب الذي سبق الانسحاب هل
نحن امام انسحاب مدبر ام انسحاب بطعم
الهزيمه
لا لا يمكن اعتباره انسحابا بفعل الهزيمه
لان العديد من الخبراء العسكريين يعتقدون
بل هم على اليقين بان روسيا بطبيعه الحال
ستحاول معاوده هذه النقطه السكنيه المهمه
جدا بالنسبه للعمليه العسكريه كلها
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان يدور الحديث عن
انسحاب كي اشاره الى هزيمه القوات الروسيه
مناوره عسكريه هي مستوى ربما يمكن ان
ينطبق على ما يجري الان من قبل القوات
الروسيه وهي بالفعل اولا تهتم بحياه افراد
المدنيين والعسكريين
ويعني هذه الاعتبارات انسانيه وبتبيه
الحال لها مبرراتها وبالتالي ولذلك هي
حظيت بتاييد من قبل حتى اشد مؤيدين همم
الخطوات العسكريه الحاشمه في
رانيا ومنهم في المقام الاول الرئيس
الشيشاني رمضان قضيرا هو يعني بارك هذه
العمليه وايدها بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
بريكوجان وهو رئيس مجموعه فاجر العسكريه
الروسيه ايضا ايضا هذه الخطوه فان دل هذا
الشيء
قلته ماريا زخرفه المتحدثه باسمي وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه بانه الان روسيا مستعده
للحوار مع الاتحاد الاوروبي همم لايجاد
حلول شرط ان يتم اخذ ما يحصل على الارض
بعين الاعتبار هل الانسحاب الروسي
والتراجعات العسكريه الاخيره هي ما دفعت
روسيا الى اظهار هذا لين الدبلوماسي
فعليا هل نضجت الظروف لايقاف هذه الحرب
والتواصل الى حال يرد الطرفين
[موسيقى]
وبين التصريحات الاخيره التي يدلي بها
المسؤولين الروس بالمناسبه يعني تحدث عن
ضروره العوده الى الحوار جاء منذ فتره
بعيدا نسبيا
وحتى يوم اااه ضم او انضمام المناطق
الاربعه لاوكرانيا الرئيس الروسي بوتين
توجه الى القياده الاوكرانيه فدعاها الى
اجراء مضاعفات سياسيه حول تسويه هذه
الازمه وبالتالي لم يكن يعني مثل هذا
الخطاب مرتبط مباشره بلا اوضاع على الارض
الان طبعا نحن امام تطورات لا يمكن لاحد
ان يتوقع يعني نتائج
الامور سوف تكون مرهونه كما كان سابقا على
تطورات على الارض مباشره خلال الايام
القليله القادمه ومن جاء اخرى بمصاعد
دبلوماسيه وروسيا الى ترفض حوار سواء مع
اوكرانيا مباشره او عبر وسيط
المرشحين نعم نعم شكرا جزيلا لك المحلل
السياسي حدثنا من موسكو
في شان الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه ايضا قال
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
الجنرال مارشميل لان خسائر الجيش الروسي
فقط المئه الف جندي سقط بين قتيل وجريح في
اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه عانت على الارجح من مستوى
مماثل من الخسائر في الحرب وقلم اللي
منظمه نادي نيويورك الاقتصادي انا حوالي
40,000 مدني اوكراني قتلوا ايضا في الصراع
منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا تصريحات ملي تعتبر اعلى تقدير
امريكي لعدد الضحايا حتى الان في الصراع
المستمر منذ حوالي تسعه اشهر
[موسيقى]
في شان المتصل انا اقترحات المفوضيه
الاوروبيه خطه تسمح للقوات المسلحه
بالتحرك اسرع
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الى تحرير تنقل
القوات العسكريه والعتاد المفوضيه
الاوروبيه اشارت ايضا الى ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يواجه بيئه امنيه معقده حيث
الحرب على حدودها بدوره قال مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه بالاتحاد
اوكرانيا دلت على الصعوبات التي يواجهها
الاتحاد في نقل العتاد العسكري مشيرا الى
حاجه القوات الاوروبيه لتامين خطوط
الامداد بالوقود في انحاء الاتحاد
اعلن اقل او اعلنت الحكومه البريطانيه
تجميد اصول قيمتها 18 مليار جنيه استرليني
تعود لافراد وكيانات روسيه صدرت بحقهم
عقوبات بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا وزادت
الاصول الروسيه المجمده بسته مليارات جنيه
عن المبلغ المعلني عنه في جميع انظمه
العقوبات البريطانيه الاخرى وقال وزير
الخزانه البريطاني انا رساله بلاده واضحه
وهي عدم السماح لبوتن بالنجاح في الحرب
باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
نفع مكتب اسيستاني من نسب على لساني ممثله
في ايران حول الاحتياجات الايرانيه وفق
البيان كما اشار البيان الى ان السيستاني
ليس لديه اي وكيل يعبر عن مواقفه السياسيه
يذكر ان تصريحات لجواد الشهر الثاني وهو
ممثل المرجع الديني على السيستاني في
ايران نقلت هوسائل الاعلام ايرانيه ندد
فيها بالاحتجاجات الايرانيه وابدا دعاما
للنظام الايراني
ياتي هذا التصريح من السيستاني في وقت
توسع رقعه الاحتجاجات في ايران لتطال هذه
المره القطعه الطبيه في البلاد حيث رفع
الاطباء الصوت عاليا بوجه النظام الايراني
احتجاجا على منعهم من علاج جرح التظاهرات
وعلى وجود قوات الامن داخل المستشفيات
واعتقال وترهيب الاطباء وفقا ما كشفته
صحيفه واشنطن بوست شهود الصحيفه ان مجموعه
من الاطباء تجمعوا امام المجلس الطبي
للاحتجاج لكن سرعان ما تعرض هؤلاء الى قمع
القوات الامنيه ومنهم من كان بزين مدني
قاموا باطلاق النار وضرب الاطباء
قالت ان عدد قليلا من المستشفيات
الايرانيه تقدم المساعده الطبيه للجرحى
والمصابين اثناء الاحتجاجات واكثر من ذلك
اوضحت الصحيفه في تقريرها ان بعض المصابين
من المتظاهرين توجهه للاطباء البيطريين
لتجنب اكتشفهم واعتقالهم من قبل السلطات
من جانب اخر من السلطات الايرانيه ايضا
الطلاب المحتجين من الدخول الى الجامعات
وعلقت دراستهم وفقا لتقرير قناه مجالس
نقبات الطلاب الايرانيين في التلجرام ياتي
ذلك في ظل التضامن الواسع من قبل الطلاب
مع الانتفاض الشعبيه في معظم جامعه البلاد
وكان نحو 6 استاذ جامعي اصدر وبيانا في
وقت سابق اعلن فيه دعمهم للاحتجاجات
القانونيه للطلاب مشددين على انهم
سيستخدمون جميع القنوات الاحتجاجيه في حال
عدم الافراج عن الطلاب المعتقل
[موسيقى]
وفي خطوه الممثله قام بها رياضيون وفنانين
واطباء ايرانيون اعلنت ممثله ايرانيه
بارزه دعمها للاحتجاجات التي تعمل البلاد
من حسابها على انستغرام
المعروفه بدفاعها عن حقوق الانسان
والمشهوره بنقل تفاصيل مقاس الواقع
الاجتماعيه الايراني في افلامها في ساعات
اشعلت كلمات القصيده التي نشرتها تراني
ثوره افتراضيه موازيه على حسابها على
انستغرام الذي يتابعها عليه قرابه ثمانيه
ملايين شخص لم تكن الكلمات وحدها الصوره
ايضا تراني قررت التمرد بصوره لها دون
حجاب رفيعه شعارا حملته الحشود الغاضبه
على مقتل شابه
منتصف سبتمبر الماضي
والحريه اسقط رموزا كما خلفها النظام
الايراني للسنوات من داخل ايران انضمت
اليدوستي الى هذه الثوره وتعاهدت بالبقاء
في وطنها باي ثمن بطلت فيلم البائع الحائز
جائزه الاوسكار عام 2016 كافضل فيلم اجنبي
تلعب اليوم دور البطوله على ارض الواقع في
تحديث وتقف عن العمل للدفاع عن عائلات
السجناء والقتلى
مكرم حناوي العربيه
وانضم الينا من لندن الباحث في الشان
الايراني يوسف عزيزي اهلا بك سيد يوسف
يعني ما رايك بموقف السيستاني الذي نفى ما
تنقلته وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه عن موقفه من
الاحتجاجات الرجل نفى وجود ممثل له اصلا
يتحدث باسمه
الشهر الثاني الذي يدعي هو
ممثله في لندن همم وهذا امر مهم لانه همم
هناك مقلدين
للسيستاني في ايران
واخذوا يتملون من هذا الموقف الذي هو شهر
الثاني باسم همم
لكن همم فيه هذا الامر يعني في الواقع همم
هؤلاء الناس ونحن نعرف
السيستاني يختلف مع
علي خامنيه المرشدي الاعلى في ايران ولا
يعتقد بتدخل السياسه بشكل مباشر في
همم ال ال رجال الدين بشكل مباشر
من الكتاب والفنيين والرياضيين بهذا
الاحتجاجات ما دورهم وانت حضرتك عضو
باتحاد الكتاب الايرانيين دوركم في هذه
الاحتجاجات
والرياضيين والفنانين دور هام لانه
يتابعونهم الملايين من البشر ومن
المواطنين في ايران وانتم اشدتهم الى
ترانا على دوستي الممثله الايرانيه والتي
لها كما ذكرتم ثمان ثمان ملايين تابع
متابع في همم الانستغرام همم لا يؤثرون
على الجماهير
ويشدون على عزمهم كي همم يستمر في همم
نظارهم ضد همم النظام
الكهنوتي الاستبدادي همم في ايران وهذا
ليس همم اليوم والان امس في همم مثلا
الاتحاد القطام اللي انا افتخر بعضوته همم
لعب دورا في عام
1978 و 79
في دعمه لنظالات الشعوب الايرانيه ضد حكم
الشاهد الاستبدادي وايضا انتقد خلال هذه
السنوات ال 44 كل ما قام به النظام الحالي
من قمع ورقابه على الكتاب وعلى على حريه
التعبير
وقدما الشهداء يعني كلوا الشهداء يعني
العشرات من من زملائنا قتلوا على يد بقوات
الامن الايرانيه بشكله اخر خلال هذه
السنوات ليس همم
لمعارضتهم همم للقمع
والرقابه على الكتاب والصحافه وما شان ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن الباحث في شان
الايراني يوسف عزيز
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بنجانس ان
بلاده لديها القدره على تنفيذ عمليات ضد
المنشات النوويه في ايران واكد غانس ان
قواتها حققت الجاهزيه ولديها المزيد من
القدرات والعمليات طويله الامد لضرب
مشاريع ايران النوويه وكان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي كشف في اغسطس الماضي ان
اسرائيل يجب ان تستعد لعمل عسكري وحدي
الجانب ضد برنامج ايران النووي
شدد المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافايل جروستي على ان اعلان ايران
تصنيعا صواريخ باليستيه يفاقم المخاوف
الدوليه من برامجها الصاروخيه واوضح جراسي
في تصريحات خلال حضوره مؤتمر المناخ في
شرم الشيخ ان هذه الاعلانات تفاقم المخاوف
وتزيد الانتباه الى الملف النووي الايراني
مؤكدا ان لذلك تاثيرا على جميع الموضوعات
المرتبطه بايران
في المحادثات مع ايران بشان مواد نوويه
غير معلن عنها في ثلاثه مواقع مع وجود خطه
لاجراء زياره الى طهران هذا الشهر
الاخبار او ما اذا كنا نحرز تقدما في
تحقيقاتنا المفتوحه وليس سرا اننا لم
نتمكن من تسجيل بعض العناصر الملموسه
لدينا فرصه لاعاده المشاركه او لمواصله
عملنا ولكن هذا سيحدث بعد صدور تقاريره
مستمره وفيها بعض الفصل
بعد كوريا الجنوبيه امريكا واليابان
تطلقان التدريبات العسكريه مشتركه ضخمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد انطلقت اليوم التدريبات
العسكريه المشتركه بين امريكا واليابان
احد اضخم المناورات القتاليه بين البلدين
والتي جاءت في عقاب تكثيف اطلاق الصواريخ
من قبل كوريا الشماليه اضافه الى زياده
مطالب الصين في البحر الجنوبي والشرقي من
جانبها كشفت وزيره الدفاع اليابانيه عن
مشاركه اكثر من 26 الف جندي امريكي
وثلاثين سفينه وما تجاوز من
370 طائره من امريكا واليابان في هذه
التدريبات
يتدفق شهريا عبر الشواطئ الجنوبيه لليمن
6000 مهاجر من القرن الافريقي تقول
السلطات بان المهاجرين يدخلون بشكل غير
شرعي وان معظمهم ينتشرون في الاسواق
والشوارع ويعيشون في العراق
كما تقول السلطات المحليه
يوما من دون تسجيل وصول عشرات المهاجرين
من دول القرن الافريقي وخصوص الاثيوبيا
الهجره
الى عدن سبنا مشكله امنيه مشكله صحيه ايضا
شارم في وسط الاسواق وبين الله السكنيه
لا كان في الاخير نحن نتعامل الانسان
عوده هذه المهاجرين الى مناطقم خاصه وهجره
غير الشرعيه وليس ولا يدخلوا في اطار
اللاجئين يشكلها او لا يعيب عن كبيرا
وباطن يفاقم من الازمات التي تعيشها
وتعاني منها مدينه عدن والمحافظات
المجاوره
ويتدفق شهريا عبر الشواطئ الجنوبيه للبلاد
6000 مهاجر بمعدل شهري وتقول السلطات ان
هؤلاء المهاجرين يدخلون بشكل غير شرعي وان
معظمهم يرفضون البقاء في مخيمات الاستقبال
لينتشروا بشكل غير منظم في الاسواق
والشوارع والاحياء ويعيشون في العراق
بمساعده ما يفوق 3000 مهاجر بالعوده
الطبيعيه الى ابو الدنيا من الاصل طبعا
الرقم في ارتفاع اا بسبب تزايد عدد
المهاجرين الموجودين هنا والذين تقاطعت
بهم السبل والذين يطلبون طبعا مساعد
المنظمه الدول الهجره
تؤرق السكان بما يجبهم من المشكلات
وتداعيات وانتشار للجريمه
والاستغلال الذي وصل الى حد تجنيد بعضهم
واستخدامهم في تنفيذ عمليات ارهابيه من
قبل تنظيم القاعده والحسين
انه نحن بالرحل ولكن العدد ما زالت تتواصل
علينا وكان هناك في غدا اجتماع بالخارجيه
اليمنيه مع الحكومه الاثيوبيه على دوله
عقد مؤتمر الدولي للحد من الهجره هذه في
القرن الافريقي مرارا كررت سلطاته عدن
والحكومه الدعوات لمنظمه الهجره الدوليه
للمساعده في ايجاد حلول لمشكله المهاجرين
من افريقيا وحتى تاتي استجابتهم تاخرت
كثيرا تبقى هذه الظاهره واحده من اكبر
المشاكل التي تواجهها ذلك العربيه
قال وزير الداخليه الفرنسي جيرالدر مانينا
ان بلاده ستستقبل ركاب سفينه انقاذ
المهاجرين تقطعت بهم السبل في البحر
الابيض المتوسط منذ اكثر من اسبوعين بعد
ان رفضت ايطاليا دخولهم مضيفا ان فرنسا
ستستقبل حوالي 230 راكبا من سفينه اوشن
فايكنج في الميناء العسكري في مدينه تونس
اذ بدا خفرست سواحل الفرنسي في وقت سابق
عمليه اجلاء طبي لسفينه انقاذ المهاجرين
التي كانت متوجهه من او الى كوستاريكا
كرسيكا فعليا على امل ان تقدم فرنسا
سريركا بها من امنا
كشف كريم خان المدعي العام للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه عن حصوله على ادله
ومعلومات بشان ما زعم تتعلق بجرائم ارتكبت
في ترهونه بليبيا وذلك بعد تفقده مقابر
جماعيه هناك راسما صوره مروعه لما شهده
على حدث ذلك
في كمبوديا وشاهدت الدمار في سيبيريا
والبلقان ورواندا وشاهدت المقابر الجماعيه
لداعش ترهون اظهرت لنا درجات الحرمان
العاليه ظروف صعبه جدا واوضاع مروعه لا
حقوق ولا كرامه حتى للموته في اي كون واي
زمان يحدث ذلك علينا ان نحققه لمعرفه من
هو المسؤول عن ذلك
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس المخابرات الالمانيه الاسبق
اوجست هانينج للعربيه ان المنظمات الدينيه
التي تتخطى الخط الاحمر يتم اغلاقها لكن
اثبات ذلك امر معقد وهو سبب تاني المانيا
بحاضر منظمات دينيه مرتبطه بايران
لا تهدا التظاهرات الايرانيه في المانيا
التي تطالب الحكومه بالتشدد اكثر مع طهران
بدات التظاهرات في ايران والعلاقه بين
برلين وطهران تحولت الى ماده جدلا سياسي
هنا حزب المعارضه الرئيسي المسيح
الديمقراطي الذي تنتمي اليه المستشاره
السابقه انجيل ميركل لم يتردد باتهام
الحكومه باعتماد سياسه لينه مع طهران خلال
جلسه صوت فيها النواب لتبني ورقه تطالب
الحكومه بالتشدد اكثر مع ايران والنائب
كريستيانو
حتى ان الوقت لم يعد مناسبا للابقاء على
الحوار مفتوحا مع طهران والتمسك بالاتفاق
النووي
تدفعت بسياسه المهادنه اتجاه ايران كانت
هناك مطالبات واضحه من الليبراليين مثلا
لاغلاق مركز الاسلامي ولكن حزب الخضر
رغم ان كل الحقائق على الطاوله والمركز
المراقب من المخابرات منذ 30 عاما
ليس بهذه السهوله يقول الرئيس السابق
للمخابرات الالمانيه او كوستارينج الذي
كان جهازه يراقب مركزه همبرج منذ اركانه
هو رئيسه بين العامين
1998 و205 بسبب نشاطات
يمكن ان يمارس ديانته بحريه ولهذا نفصل
بين الدين
تجمعات الدينيه ولكن عندما تستخدم
الديانات اداه سياسيه او للتحريض على
العنف فهذا خط الاحمر
بحقوق الانسان
الحكومه الالمانيه ترفض انتقادات المعارضه
وتؤكد ان مقاربتها لايران صحيحه فهي تريد
معاقبه النظام الايراني لتصديه للمتظاهرين
ولكنها تبقى حريصه على ابقاء باب الحوار
مفتوحا خاصه فيما يتعلق بالملف النووي
العربيه برلين
[موسيقى]
وصل الاعصار نيكول الى الساحل الاطلسي
لولايه فلوريدا جنوب شرق الولايات المتحده
حيث صدرت اوامر باخلاء السكان لمنازلهم
حسب ما افادت الارصاد الجويه الامريكيه
[تصفيق]
قال الرئيس الامريكي ان علاقات الرئيس
التنفيذي لتويتر الماس مع الدول الاخرى
يجب النظر فيها جاء ذلك رد على سؤال عما
اذا كان ماسك يمثل تهديدا للامن القومي
اقتران تويتر باسمي له ماسك ما زالت
اصداؤه تتوالى كل ما هدات امواج صفقه
الاستحواذ على الشركه الاقتصاديه تتعالى
من جديد من الجانب السياسيه هذه المره قد
يقف ماسك في مواجهه محتمله مع بيض الذي
صرح بانه يجب التحقيق بعلاقات ماسك بالدول
اجنبيه وتاثيرها على الامن القومي
كوكو
بعد دعوه عدوين في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
ينتميان للحزب الديمقراطي الى اجراء
التدقيق في صفقه تويتر بحجه مدى تاثير
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه في الشركه على توجيه
دفه الانتخابات الامريكيه رغم ان معظم هذه
الاستثمارات كانت موجوده قبل استحواذ
ايلوكا لذلك يربطها البعض بنتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه التي تقدم بها الحزب
الجمهوري على مستوى مجلس النواب
باب الخلاف بين بيض وماسك جاء بعد تهنئه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب له على صفقه
استحواذ تويتر انا سعيد جدا لان تويتر
اصبحت الان في ايد امينه ولن يديرها بعد
الان مجانين يساريون راديكاليون يكرهون
بلدنا بالفعل
تطور دفع بيض لمهاجمه مصر بقوه ما يقلقنا
الان جميعا هو قيام ايلون ماسك بشراء اداه
ترسل وتنشر الاكاذيب في انحاء العالم كيف
نتوقع ان يتحلى الاطفال بالقدره على ادراك
المخاطر اما ماسك فانتقد مؤخرا وضع
الاقتصاد الامريكي في ظل ادارتي
الاقتصاد الامريكي في حاله ركود وارتفاع
الاسعار نتيجه بسيطه لطباعه النقود ادعو
الشركات لمراقبه تكاليف والتدفقات النقديه
سواء داخل الولايات المتحده او خارجها لا
يتوقف ماسك عن اثاره الجدل بارائه
السياسيه فمن تقديم مقترح لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه وصولا الى حل ازمه تايوان
والصين تتعرض اراء ماسك مع توجهات
الادارات الامريكيه الحاليه وهو ما قد
يصاعد من حده الخلاف وعواقبه على تويتر
علي السمان العربيه
في النواب حتى الان
بعد انسحاب روسيا القوات الاوكرانيه تتقدم
في خرسونه وتحذيرات من كمين روسي
[موسيقى]
اسيستاني يكذب اعلام ايران وينفي اي
تصريحات نصبت اليه حول موقف رافض
للاحتجاجات وداعم النظام
بيان امريكيون اوروبي يصف هجوم الحوثي على
ميناء قناب الارهابي ويطالب
بالقانون الدولي